foreign
daily cancellation we turn belatedly to
a story that unfolded last week but
which must not escape the wrath of the
daily cancellation it's just too perfect
the segment was made for cases like this
this is uh the story of Elizabeth
Gilbert who's the author of the 2006 hit
Memoir Eat Pray Love which Chronicles
her mission to find herself and discover
the deeper truth truths of life after
her divorce now like any vapid
self-absorbed upper middle class woman
she does this by going on vacation for
whatever reason lots of other women at
the time were deeply interested in
reading this lady's travel blog about
her experiences as a tourist in various
tropical locations as we all know there
are generally two kinds of stories that
are always sure to be incredibly boring
and trite there are dream stories
because your dreams are never
interesting to anyone but you and then
there are stories about cliched
epiphanies that you had while on
vacation and those are never interesting
either because no your vacation was not
life-changing uh you were you were you
when you left for vacation and you were
you the whole time you were on vacation
and you return as you the same person
that you were before unfortunately your
Jamaican Cruise isn't going to change
that
as it happens shallow liberal women are
especially inclined to tell both types
of stories and this was a book devoted
to one of them she probably also talked
about her dreams in the book though I
can't say for sure but now somehow
nearly 20 years later Elizabeth Gilbert
is the author of something even more
embarrassing than you pray love this new
work may be called Eat Pray cower like a
scared puppy because indeed Gilbert is
now responsible for what might be
the most pathetic and humiliating
surrender of all time she makes France
and World War II look stalwart by
comparison
this is truly one for the record books
and I say this only a couple of weeks
after Blue Jay's pitcher Anthony bass
grovel to the LGBT cult like we talked
about begging their forgiveness for
committing the crime of thinking for
himself and then a few days later he was
cut from the team anyway and that was
humiliating that was disgraceful that
was an absolute master class in
self-flagellation Anthony bass has a PHD
and be clowning himself
but it still pales in comparison to this
two weeks ago Elizabeth Gilbert
excitedly announced her new book now
surprisingly it's not another Memoir
detailing her weekend trip to Myrtle
Beach and all the Deep insights into the
mysteries of the universe that she
picked up along the way instead this is
a novel
set in the mid 20th century in Siberia
and it centers around a group of people
who resisted the Soviet government and
she says try to defend nature against
industrialization whatever that means
it's called the snow Forest because it
takes place in a forest in the snow
that's how she came up with the title
Gilbert has never been known for
creative titles
as for whatever else might happen in the
book I will personally never find out
because I would never read in Elizabeth
Gilbert book and second nobody will find
out because nobody will read this
particular book she has retracted it she
has retracted the entire book pulled it
from publication
and she's done this because some people
were offended that the novel is set in
Russia
they are offended that her fiction novel
about mid-20th Century Freedom Fighters
in Siberia takes place in Russia
and she is responding to these
complaints by junking the book that she
had spent the last many months writing
here she is explaining that decision
listen
hi everybody it's Liz and I have an
announcement to make so last week I
announced the upcoming publication of my
most recent novel a book called the snow
Forest that was set in the middle of
Siberia in the middle of the last
century and told the story of a group of
individuals who made a decision to
remove themselves from society to resist
the Soviet government and to try to
defend nature against industrialization
but over the course of this weekend I
have received an enormous massive
outpouring of reactions and responses
from my Ukrainian readers expressing
anger
sorrow
disappointment and pain
about the fact that I would choose to
release a book into the world right now
any book no matter what the subject of
it is that is set in Russia
and I want to say that I have heard
these messages and read these messages
and I respect them and as a result I'm
making a course correction and I'm
removing the book from its publication
schedule it is not the time for this
book to be published and
um
I do not want to add
any harm
to a group of people who have already
experienced and who are all continuing
to experience Grievous and extreme harm
so that is the choice that I have made
and I've got other book projects that
I'm working on and I've made a decision
to turn my attention to working on those
now so I just wanted to let everybody
know that and thank you very much
she has other book projects she's
working on she says hopefully before
complete completing those other books
she will gather together a group of gay
trans disabled polysexual queer lesbian
ukrainians and get clearance for every
character Theme plot Point uh setting in
the book
she must make sure that it All Passes
muster especially with the poor folks of
Ukraine who we're told are in a war for
their very existence and yet still have
the time and energy to get offended by a
book from the Eat Pray lovewoman
offended because it simply is set in
Russia which is the the possibly the
dumbest reason that anyone has ever been
offended by anything
not just offended she says they are
burdened the book is a burden to them
somehow it is a cross that they must
carry using the internet without
expressvpn is like forgetting to turn
off your camera on zoom and everyone
sees you picking your nose or doing
something embarrassing uh internet
service providers they know every single
website you visit they can sell this
information to ad tech companies and
Tech Giants who then use your data to
Target you expressvpn reroutes your
network data through a secure encrypted
tunnel so your service providers can't
see or sell your online activity I love
expressvpn because it's so simple to use
you just fire up the app click one
button and you're good to go plus it
works on phones laptops and even routers
so everyone who shares your Wi-Fi can be
protected your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com Walsh right
now to get three extra months for free
that's expressvpn.com Walsh to get
protected right now expressvpn.com Welsh
companies are strong arming their
customers to support abortion canceling
customers for their political views and
making a mockery of women by supporting
transgender models no government agency
institution or company is allowed to
just be what it is and focus on
fulfilling the tasks that it was made to
fulfill a beer company can't just make a
beer anymore their primary concern is
not with brewing and distributing beer
but with showing their support of the
less political and cultural agenda
that's why we need Public Square which
offers a new solution Public Square is
an app and a website where you can get
connected to tens of thousands of
businesses from all different industries
that share your value for Life family
and freedom Public Square also offers
discounts to many high quality
businesses on the platform so you can
actually have an incentive to spend
money with companies that don't hate you
imagine that whether you're looking for
a new athletic clothing that knows what
a woman is a banking partner you can
count on or simply a new restaurant in
your area that won't lecture you about
your political views as you're trying to
enjoy a meal with your family head over
to
publicsq.com Public Square is free to
join as a consumer or a business owner
you can get started at publicescue.com
or download their app today that's
public s q.com now Gilbert does the
familiar song and dance here she says
that the motivations and intentions of
the person causing offense her in this
case don't matter
context doesn't matter and obviously she
wasn't trying to offend her Ukrainian
readers who are apparently the most
fragile and shallow people to ever walk
the earth she wasn't trying to paint
Russia in a good light God forbid
she's well aware that she's supposed to
hate the whole country and anyone who's
ever lived there she's aware that being
Russian is a character flaw these days
but this book doesn't contradict that
bigotry in fact the Russian government
the Soviet government are rightly the
bad guys in this book
given that it takes place during the
Soviet Union era and yet the very
mention of the country was too much to
bear
there is no coherent reason for the mob
to be offended but they are
her actions became offensive the moment
the mob decided that they were going to
be offended
and their emotions must not be questions
their demand their demands must not be
scrutinized
she must simply bow to them unthinkingly
and in fear
this is always how it works with the
outrage mob they are the authorities on
your own actions they get to decide what
you were thinking what you intended they
get to make totally arbitrary rules
governing both your thoughts and your
actions
and this week they decided to make the
rule that you aren't allowed to write a
book set in Russia
no matter the actual subject or point of
the book
this kind of arbitrary rulemaking by the
way is destroying the book publishing
industry uh in this country and just as
it's destroying the film industry
speaking of which just in the last few
weeks
we've seen two big budget films from
Major Movie Studios fall on their faces
at the box office the Pixar film
Elemental and the superhero movie The
Flash were both Duds despite the fact
that Pixar films and superhero films as
a category were once Surefire successes
and there are a lot of reasons why
people don't care about these movies
anymore partly it's pure exhaustion from
the same stories and themes being
recycled a million times partly it's the
wokeness that Pixar film had the first
non-quote-unquote non-binary character
in The Pixar Universe partly it's the
fact that the actual quality of these
films from the acting to the writing
even to the special effects has declined
tremendously
I saw one scene from The Flash that
looked like a PlayStation game in 2002
but underlying all of these problems is
the basic fact
that movies aren't allowed to just tell
a story anymore the same goes for books
if you tell a story through whatever
medium you are presenting a certain
point of view and a certain world that
you have created with characters that
have certain uh personality traits and
do certain things and say certain things
and this all requires you to make
choices as a Storyteller it means that
you're choosing to tell the story one
way and not another and you're putting
forward one point of view instead of
another and you have these characters uh
doing this instead of different
characters doing something else and all
of these choices are sure to offend one
interest group or another
there's always going to be some group
left out or underrepresented or
represented in a way that they find
offensive or traumatic Etc and so forth
the nitpicking the offense taking the
pathological persecution complex that
that so many people carry around every
day all of this has made storytelling
impossible
it has killed stories
and created the first Society in human
history with no story to tell
of course there is a way around this
there is a solution
all of these rules and demands from the
outrage masses they don't have to mean
anything
they don't have to carry any weight
you do have the option of simply
ignoring all of this
when they decree a new rule that they
invented in their imaginations this
morning you can always respond by
telling them to piss off
and then continuing to proceed to do
whatever it is that you were going to do
anyway
when they say that they're burdened and
they're hurt and deeply wounded and
traumatized by some innocuous thing or
statement or plot theme or storytelling
choice
you do have the option of laughing in
their pathetic manipulative faces
Gilbert could have doubled down and
issued a statement announcing that
she'll now be writing a whole series of
books set in Russia and Putin will be
the hero just despite all these weepy
little clowns
but if she didn't want to commit to a
new series of books simply out of spite
which I guess would be understandable
then she could have at least told them
all to kiss her ass in so many words
that was an option
it's always an option when facing the
outrage mop the middle finger option we
might call it
the option we should all be choosing
when confronted by these people
certainly the only option that will
rescue the film industry and the book
publishing industry from annihilation
but Gilbert didn't choose that option
she decided to debase herself and throw
out her own work months of effort
to appease a bunch of dumb soulless
crybabies
she chose not to offend
even though offending these people is
not only okay but a virtue it is The
Virtuous path
she chose the unvirtuous path
and for that reason Elizabeth Gilbert is
today canceled hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there